[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the 8 news now coverage
of the Vegas strong 5K and you know Nate
when we talk about Las Vegas we talk
about the glittering lights and the City
Lights the true lights are the people
the true lights are the ones our
community who lives here who've come out
today to be a part of this incredible
event and the healing process for so
many we've talked about this being the
fifth anniversary of the one October
tragedy and it in a lot of ways it seems
like it was just yesterday in a lot of
ways it's like I cannot believe it's
been five years and here we are a lot of
folks coming up to say hello we're
getting selfies we're having a good time
talking to people but most of the
runners are on a course right now and I
believe Heather we're going to find out
a little bit more with Sherry who's
still in the middle of it over there hey
Sherry
hi you guys well with me right now is
Cynthia Gainey she is the founder and
director of the Vegas strong 5K and uh
the founder of just run your running
event company
um tell us we just kind of at the tail
end of everybody going through why is
this so near and dear to your heart you
started this through your heart talked
to you five years ago it was important
for you to do this and what have you
seen in the last five years
well the importance of us I grew up in
Las Vegas and uh is my home nothing ever
like this had happened before and you
know a lot of my relatives and everybody
says oh Las Vegas is just you know
gambling and shows and things like that
and when everybody came together after
this happened I mean it proved that we
are a community we're not just the strip
and so because we have this race
management company we wanted to do
something more than just give money but
because we had it I said well let's put
on a race we can raise funds for the
victims fund and we Our intention was
just to have it the first year but after
everybody came together and coming
together with support and love and
healing and they just said please have
it every year so we about to continue to
have it every year so I just saw
Rosemarie Melanson walk past she was one
of the she was injured and she went
through so many surgeries and her road
to Healing was long but her family is
here every year now tell me a little a
bit about what that means to you and to
keep putting on this event for people
like Rosemary and her family well it
just shows that with this kind of an
event it it gives you strength to like I
said move forward One Foot In Front of
the other to get to that ultimate goal
whatever that is for you whatever Finish
Line it is and those her daughters they
were the ones here first and then the
rest of the family started coming and
then when Rosemarie was able to then
they were all here with Grandma and um
it's just every year they get more and
more strong and it's just it's a really
it's an inspiration it's amazing what
you've done and what you did in seven
weeks that first year and what you've
done in five years so thank you so much
and raising over a quarter of a million
dollars for all these victims funds and
scholarships thank you Cynthia Gainey
we're gonna go out on the course now
we're going to see some of the people
walking and running JC Fernandez is out
there show us what's going on JC
hey Sherry thank you we're actually at
the Finish Line we're waiting for some
people to cross the finish line for the
first time the race started about 10
minutes ago so we should get some people
coming across is this our first is this
the first one to finish hold on one
second did you just finish the race hey
buddy did you just finish the race
okay what's your name Declan Declan you
know how fast you ran buddy no you were
very fast why are you out here running
today because because of October 1st
that's right well congratulations what a
great job good job buddy there are some
fast Runners out here and here comes
some more Runners and there's
celebrities out here someone told me
that Miranda Lambert is out here and
then of course our fellow Las Vegas and
what is your name Natalie Carson and
Natalie who are you guys out here for
today wherever Rosemary Melanson and she
was a friend of yours yes friend of ours
and um she was one of the victims um and
she was shopping thankfully she
recovered and she's here walking with us
today we're here with us Cinderella
scholarship program and supporting her
and what does this day mean to you why
are you out here today well the people
who I care about that I'm here today
they are my dance teachers and they were
in this stuff specially Miss Rosemary
because she survived it's amazing thank
you guys for being here showing her
support I know you want to go join your
friends so you can you can start walking
thank you so much for being here good
luck start walking you guys and more
more people cross the finish line that
is a fast pace here comes some more
people running right now and I love it
it's families running together
here comes a father and son and look
I'll get this guy real fast when he
finishes over here
[Music]
Let's uh come over here congratulations
you just finished the race how does it
feel
exhilarating exhilarating so what's your
name Ben Ben why are you out here today
buddy
um mostly because my dad dragged me out
here but he's honest he's honest but how
does it feel to finish the race and
knowing you're running for a great cause
feels good yeah yeah I feel proud you're
fast you know that yeah you're real fast
buddy all right now you finish the race
go grab some water there's your buddy
two of the fastest kids in Las Vegas
here congratulations good job guys all
right uh we're waiting for more Runners
to come across we also have the the fun
walk that's taking place the one mile
fun walk so everybody's gonna come
eventually cross this Finish Line but
for now I'm gonna send it back to Nate
and Heather I'll send back to you guys
boy JC that is truly remarkable that's
like a five minute mile man I thought I
saw a smoke going behind me which is
incredible breathing hard and we also
have great groups of Runners we heard
the Marines yes they were gearing up and
they were they were shouting out there's
a lot of chance we've seen a lot of dogs
a lot of dogs and tutus just people out
here having fun and it's that
camaraderie and the reason that we love
this city so much because we truly are
Vegas strong and there's even some eight
news now folks here too let's talk about
that they're Milling about
but we do need to take a break and the
eight news now live coverage of the
Vegas strong fifth annual 5K we'll be
right back